ANNA PATTERSON: Now I want to
introduce Johanna Wright.
She's the Lead Product Manager
of Search for many years,
launching such innovations as
Universal Search, Instant, and
the Knowledge Graph.
And now she's leading up Search
in Android, including
Google Now, Voice Search,
and Speech.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Let's step
back to January 2003.
At this point in time,
I'm living in my
father in-law's house.
He's put a nice curtain up for
my section of the living room,
where my husband and I share
an air mattress.
The sun streams in.
6:00 AM we wake up every
morning because of the
unbearable Orange County heat.
Air mattress is popped,
and I'm unemployed.
Just six months earlier, I was a
young tech exec in New York,
first during the dot-com
boom and then bust.
But my company that I worked at
had finally shut its doors.
And my husband and I decided
to get on our bicycles and
ride across the country
to lovely, sunny LA.
Riding across the country
with your new
husband is a lot of fun.
Showing up in LA, a new city,
with no job, not so much fun.
Then the rejection letters from
business schools started
pouring in.
And it's January, and there's
only one business school I
haven't heard back from.
But I'm not feeling too
optimistic because they're
supposed to interview all of
their candidates, and they're
going to mail out their verdict
two days later, and
they still haven't
interviewed me.
But then I got an email from
UCLA that said we want to
interview you.
And since my confidence had been
shot, my response was,
"You do?" I was fortunate enough
to get to go to UCLA
for business school, and then
I got a job at Google.
And today I'm going to talk
about my career starting out
at Google and what it was like
to be a Product Manager at
Google and give some bits
of advice about product
management.
But my first piece of career
advice is that your career is
not going to be linear.
Expect to be disrupted.
This is a disruptive industry,
and you, too, may someday be
unemployed on your
father-in-law's couch.
What's really going to matter is
the energy and the tenacity
with which you pick yourself
up and take
on your next adventure.
OK, so let's jump into Google.
I was hired to be a Product
Manager working in Search.
My boss gave me two
options of jobs.
One was something called
Universal Search.
Universal Search was the project
where we took all the
content from our different
back ends--
maps, videos, images--
and we put them in the main
search results pane.
The other option that she gave
me was to do something called
Premium Content Search.
This is where we searched all
the content behind pay walls
and put it in the
search results.
Both these things seemed pretty
interesting, and I was
so new to Google, I didn't have
any context or judgment
to make a decision.
Fortunately for me, I had gone
to the same business school as
Susan Wojcicki, my fellow
panelist, and so I asked her
for some advice.
Susan looked at me like
I had two heads.
What?
Of course you should do
Universal Search.
That's our business, Johanna.
So this leads to another
piece of career wisdom.
What does a good opportunity
look like?
Well, a good opportunity
looks like
something that's strategic.
If you're doing something
that's in line with the
company's mission and it has
not been done before, well,
then it's very likely to
be a good opportunity.
OK, so let me jump into
Universal Search.
This was 2005 at Google.
Google was growing like crazy.
It was very chaotic.
And it's kind of
hard to know--
for me it was hard to know how
projects got assigned, what
you're working on.
And I got paired up with an
infrastructure team while I
was working on Universal
Search.
This was a great team, but a
team that was very focused on
building infrastructure,
and they didn't want
to build any features.
And I was a Product Manager, and
I was being judged on the
features that I launched.
And so it was pretty stressful,
because I wasn't
delivering anything.
And so what I ended up doing was
creating a set of mocks, a
series of mocks of what
Universal Search could look
like, and then I created a
little PowerPoint deck, and I
walked around Google, and I
introduced myself to anyone
who looked like they might want
to be a Features Tech
Lead to see if they wanted
to join my project.
And I was fortunate enough to
meet a person named David
Bailey, who wanted to join on
and lead the features side of
the effort.
And then the project really
started to get legs.
So here's the beginning of my
product management specific
advice, and that is
to paint a vision.
Once you paint a vision and you
share your vision, people
will follow.
It'll be a lot easier to follow
once you have a vision.
OK, so David and I started.
There was a big mountain
in front of us.
We didn't really know
what to do.
This project had failed a
number of times before.
We didn't really know
why it had failed.
And I had this idea that we
should do a user study.
Just trying to figure out what
to do, we said, well, let's
just do a user study.
So we pulled together
a prototype
to do our user study.
And once we had this prototype,
the people around
us in Google started to be
able to imagine that this
product might come to life and
that something might happen.
And so this brings me to my
second piece of product
management advice, which is that
if you don't really know
what to do, you should
just do something.
Do something to move
the ball forward.
I was very fortunate, though,
that a user study was what we
decided to do, because
people loved it.
And it was so awesome.
We learned that the project
and the product had legs.
So I remember sitting in the
labs, and it was in the spring
of 2006, for our user study.
And one of the searches
we asked people to
do was Barry Bonds.
Now, this was a long time ago.
This was the Dark Ages.
YouTube was just starting out.
But there was a home video that
someone had uploaded of
Barry Bonds tying Babe Ruth's
home run record.
And the participant in our
study, she clicked on the
video, she watched the ball sail
out into the field, and
she had this big smile
on her face.
It wasn't unnatural at all that
she saw this video in the
search results.
So we knew the project
had legs, and it was
just a great moment.
So my final and most important
piece of product management
advice is to listen
to your users.
And even more importantly, use
your products yourself.
Just this weekend when I was
using Android Search, I
noticed that speech recognition
is slow, like
maybe one in seven times.
I don't know why, but I'm
really glad that we're
investing in speed.
Then I also had some magical
experiences with Google Now.
So I was invited to go to a
birthday party in Burlingame,
and Google Now reminded
me about the party.
And it even told me that
Burlingame was 30 minutes from
my house, which I didn't know,
and it was super helpful.
The more you use your products,
the easier it is to
make decisions and to have an
intuitive feel for what you
should be doing.
So let's summarize my product
management advice.
One, paint a vision.
Two, when you don't know what
to do, just make mini
milestones.
Roll that ball forward.
And three, use your products.
Since this is a Women's
Techmakers event, I thought
I'd close with my very
own lean-in story.
So back when all this Universal
Search stuff was
going on, I ended up
getting pregnant.
And when I was eight months
pregnant, my boss, Marissa
Mayer, suggested that I lead a
team of senior engineers to
come up with the search strategy
for the next year.
Now, the search strategy, the
process, the normal process,
was to set this meeting in
mid-November, but my baby was
supposed to be born at
the end of October.
And they're like, hey, no
problem, we'll just
move the date up.
Didn't give me very much time
to prepare, and my baby was
something that you
call transverse.
So he's lying on his side, and
I had to have a C-section.
So they moved the date up.
I moved my C-section to the
very last possible date.
We met in the middle.
And on Wednesday, I gave the
strategy presentation.
On Thursday, I had my baby.
Now, this might be horrifying
to some of you, but to me it
was invigorating.
And it set me up to have a
leadership role in Search when
I returned from my leave.
And the point I want you to take
away is not that you need
to sacrifice your family
for your career.
I feel fortunate enough that
I haven't had to do that.
You see, there was no question
in my mind that given that
opportunity, I would want to
give that presentation.
And it was really huge that
my manager believed in me.
So the takeaway that I'd like
us to take is that as
managers, we shouldn't assume
people's abilities or desires.
We should ask.
As managers, it's our job to
enable greatness in our teams.
[APPLAUSE]